Alara Trump, is it Laura or Laura?
Laura Trump is Donald Trump's daughter in
law.
She's the wife of Donald Trump's son, Eric
Trump, and she's been increasingly erratic
and cartoonishly histrionic in her appearances
on a bunch of different right wing media programs
lately.
She appeared over the weekend on a few shows
in this first clip I'm going to play for you.
She insists that the election is not over.
Don't you dare think Joe Biden will be sworn
in on January 20th, which, of course, he will
be sworn in on January 20th because Donald
Trump stops being president on January 20th
at noon.
But she says, don't you dare think that we're
fighting all the way to the end.
I want to make it very clear to the American
people this is not over.
So don't for a second think that Joe Biden
is going to be sworn in on January 20th.
Joe Biden, of course, will be sworn in on
January 20th.
And what she means by the American people
shouldn't think it's over is their donors
shouldn't think it's over because they should
keep donating money, 50 percent of which Trump
is using not to file recounts or legal challenges,
but to pay off his own campaign debt.
That's what she really means by that, Larry.
Trump also appeared on Judge Jeanine Pirro
is outrageous propaganda show on Fox News.
And when Lara Trump brings up all the court
filings, Jeanine actually seems to be like
two percent connected to reality and points
out that the courts aren't being moved by
these court filings.
And of course, they're not because the court
filings are bogus.
Check out that moment from the interview.
State legislatures in so many states, they
have held hearings in several states where
we've been able to bring witnesses forward
to tell their own testimony about what they
saw, what happened to them.
And yet you hear some of these.
It's not.
But you know what?
The Constitution, Judge Jeanine, is correct.
And, of course, with Rudy Giuliani now positive
for covid, it's unclear whether he's even
going to be able to continue doing these court
filings, which are bogus anyway.
And that same episode of Judge Jeanine Pirro
is weekend propaganda.
Our Larra Trump casually says Trump won Georgia
and also won the election in a landslide.
And Jeanine Pirro is a statue.
She doesn't.
If you're watching, you will notice Jeanine
Pirro does not even move as Larry Trump says
this.
You know, Donald Trump won the state of Georgia.
We know he won this election in a landslide.
And we're going to prove that very, very soon.
How much of their own base do you think believes
that at this point?
Because remember that a couple of weeks ago,
it's actually crazy.
It's been almost a month now.
It's been more than a month since the election,
about a month since this poll.
There was a poll that showed 60 percent of
Trump voters believed that Rudy's hearings
and lawsuits and stuff like that would overturn
the election results and lead to Donald Trump
getting a second term starting in just about
a month.
I have to imagine that that number has declined
since the hearings clearly have gone nowhere.
Right.
Like it could.
I'm guessing maybe 40 percent of Trump voters
now believe that this is actually going to
work.
It must be declining, although I'd love to
see new data on it.
And then this next moment is really sort of
a keen insight into the way that Donald Trump
does business.
This is it's it's unintentional genius.
I would call it.
Larra Trump sort of says the quiet part out
loud.
She says, listen, Trump did a favor to Georgia
Republican Governor Brian Kemp.
Trump helped Brian Kemp become governor.
And now Brian Kemp needs to do Donald Trump
a favor, which is code for figure out a way
to overturn the results, even though Joe Biden
won.
This is how they operate.
Who cares if it's illegal?
Campo's, trump a favor.
Don't you guys understand?
You're right, Jeanine.
Governor Kemp owes his position as governor,
quite frankly, to Donald Trump.
So, you know, it would be nice if he reciprocated
in some way, not just to make sure that this
goes the way that we know what went for the
president, but for the American people.
I mean, he owes it to all of us to do that.
Right thing here that is really telling that
you're not really supposed to say that out
loud, but that is what it means to have businessman
Trump as president.
It's all favors, even if they're illegal.
And, of course, politics is favors and politics
is influence peddling in a sense.
I'm not naive to that.
But it comes down to to what degree and is
it legal? Trump lost an election and the favors
he wants include governors finding illegal
ways to disenfranchize the people that voted
for Joe Biden and gave Joe Biden a victory
in those states.
So this is all, as I've been referring to
it, kind of the last big scam.
It's the last big con.
Keep saying they won.
Keep the base engaged in order to keep raising
money, half of which isn't actually used for
what they claim it's being used for.
Half is used to pay Donald Trump's campaign
debt, with Rudy now having covid and the official
electoral vote happening in just a week.
What is it that people are even donating to
here?
I have no idea.
But these are really horrible people at their
core.
And as I've said before, they deserve to never
work again.
And and the opposite may happen.
Laura Trump reportedly considering running
for Senate in North Carolina.
So the Trumps may never go away.
But Will, let's let's table that discussion
until if and until it becomes a reality